welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and now that
Spiderman is officially back in the MCU
I thought I'd break down the terms and
conditions of the new contract who
doesn't enjoy reading terms and
conditions anyway there's a lot to
unpack from the new deal up day and
quite a big hint that this will be the
moment that Disney connects venom to
their Cinematic Universe throughout this
video I'm going to be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the upcoming films and if you want to
keep up-to-date with all of the breaking
news surrounding the situation then make
sure you subscribe to the channel anyway
thanks for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown okay so during
all of the prior spider-man films Sony
financed Disney to make the movies and
from this Disney received a 5% split of
the profit share Disney were allowed to
use the character in their crossover
events and also gain merchandising
rights however once the contract was up
Disney reportedly wanted to renegotiate
the terms of the deal and together they
would Co finance the films with Sony in
return for a 50/50 split on the revenue
this caused everything to collapse on a
scale worsened Anna swiping out 50% of
all life in the universe and for the
last month it's been pretty up and down
being a spider-man fan now there have
been several sources reporting that
negotiations were still ongoing and this
turned out to be true when yesterday's
Sony and Disney both announced that
going forward they will be working on a
third film in the spider-man trilogy as
well as a crossover movie starring the
wall crawler the former of these will be
released on July 16th 2021 and will
officially be part of the phase 4 slate
the deal that will be in place will
almost be identical to the prior one
however instead of 5% Disney will now
co-financed the film and take 25% from
the overall profit now if you've been
staying up-to-date with the channel
you'll know that we reported that Sony
would let Disney continue to use the
character but that venom also had to be
taken into the MCU alongside the webhead
whilst there hasn't been any official
statements in regards to this it was
heavily hinted that yesterday when
Marvel's
you do CEO Kevin Feige stated the
following I am thrilled that Spidey's
journey in the MC will continue and I
and all of us at Marvel Studios are very
excited that we get to keep working on
it spider-man is a powerful icon and
heroes whose story crosses all ages and
audiences around the globe he also
happens to be the only hero with the
super power to cross cinematic universes
so as Sony continues to develop their
own Spidey verse you never know what
surprises the future might hold now to
me this pretty much highlights that
venom will be connected to the MCU in
some form or another Sony are of course
in pre-production on venom 2 at the
moment as well as their Morbius movie
and after the announcement of several
other films
earlier in the week it seems likely that
the so nice light will be interweaved
with some of the upcoming movies now we
do know from reports from Collider that
Tom Holland did originally shoot a cameo
for venom
however Disney asked the studio to
remove it and they did now we never got
an official statement on this but
personally I believe that this was
probably done because the character was
dead in infinity war which would have
led to a lot of confusion with him
popping up in venom going forward though
I can't see this going ahead and I
wouldn't be surprised if Holland and
Hardy do cross paths at certain points
infamous spoiler man himself Mikey
Sutton has been one of the main voices
saying that negotiations were ongoing
this entire time and the scoop master
himself posted the following yesterday
the deal is done just as I said it would
whilst countless rage baked comic book
sites and YouTube shows drank the Sony
kool-aid and thought the door shut as I
said the door wasn't closed it was still
open Sony did the takeaway just like I
had reported and lost right now Sony is
trying to present themselves as Victor's
in their sourcing to mainstream
reporters that Marvel Studios caved in
last night the 25% take from Disney
wasn't what Sony wanted they wanted to
keep it at 5% if you recall the
resulting compromise shows which side
one Disney and Sony did a short-term
contract for now because of time
limitations they needed to sign John
watts for spider-man 3 immediately and
Disney insiders tell me that he was
willing to walk away if the next movie
wasn't certainly MCU to pick up where
far from home left off it's no
coincidence that it's being revealed
today
what is in final negotiations remember
my leak about Disney offering knowbut
watts which would pull him away from the
next spider-man completely gangster yes
did it work
I'm guessing that Mikey means that it
did work because obviously we've seen a
situation today and next he goes on to
explain how spider-man may appear in the
future Marvel Studios is seeking to have
Tom Holland appear in Secret Wars
whether this is the non Spidey MCU film
and the agreement signed by both parties
last night remains to be seen but there
is no doubt by anyone on the Marvel side
that spider-man will be in Secret Wars
not only that but Marvel Studios is
planning on having spider-man in a
supporting role for the Fantastic Four
as Reed Richards can be Peter Parker's
new mentor this is only the beginning as
I discussed from the beginning the
collaboration is too big to toss away
there are discussions of Disney and Sony
sharing a cinematic universe and
expanded spider-verse if you will of
specific IPs guesting in each other's
films but right now it's time for a
victory lap you'll fly in the ointment
Mikey Sutton this is of course really
interesting as one of spider-man's first
major appearances was in the Fantastic
Four and it makes a lot of sense for him
to team up with Marvel's first family I
completely agree with certain that the
collaboration is too big to cast aside
and whilst we only have two films
officially announced for the webhead I
think that going forward there will be
much more as Sony have seen how the
situation could play out due to the fan
backlash online we have had rumors for
several months that Secret Wars will be
the next Avengers movie and if that is
the case and this could easily be where
venom is introduced similar to the comic
arc whilst there are two comic series a
Marvel called Secret Wars I can't see
the studio doing what they normally do
for the films which is to have certain
elements from prior comics crafted into
a new storyline obviously this is all a
theory at the moment but it makes sense
for marble to tie the universe together
with Sony so going forward it becomes
more difficult to separate the two
entities either way I'm glad the two
sides have worked this out and now we
know what it's like to lose the webhead
for a bit we won't want the two Studios
to separate ever again obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this
entire thing so make sure you leave them
in the comments
action below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it make sure you
check out my initial reaction to the
announcement which will be linked at the
end it's been a crazy month so make sure
you check that out if you want something
else to watch after this if you want to
come chat to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition YT
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully I
see you over there after this also just
wanna let you know that we're currently
giving away a free copy of spider-man
far from home on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the sony disney
deal in the comments section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th in the blue row be
shipped out from then to briquette
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you liked hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you